okay okay I'm Gonna Let You Go and then  I'm excited to hear what you have to say  and then we'll get to okay three points  to make okay one know your your category  and where you sit as a woman we all when  all of us are different we all require  different things we all like different  things so we lack a different type of  man  um two you said no we all like the seven  when I say when I say that I mean you  know physicality preference for example  I like black men that's my preference  it's a lot of women so you don't know I  know a lot of what I'm saying is we all  know the reality is we all we we all  don't like exactly the same things maybe  in in if you want to be generally we do  anyway absolutely don't make it cool  cool